horizon forbidden west is the
long-awaited sequel to horizon zero dawn
and throws ailoy into a beautiful but
dying world full of powerful machines as
she tries to discover why the world is
ending the game gives you a lot of
tricks up your sleeve to stop the
apocalypse again so here are nine things
i wish i knew before playing horizon
forbidden west
it might not feel like it but it has
been five whole years since horizon zero
dawn launched for playstation 4. if you
don't know your elizabeth sobek from
your ted farrow or remember exactly what
gaia and her subordinate functions did i
definitely recommend checking out a
recap before you boot up horizon
forbidden west the game takes place six
months after the events of zero dawn and
while it has a brief video explainer at
the start it's really in your best
interest to watch a recap if you haven't
played zero dawn recently trust me on
this luckily for you we made a great one
right here on gamespot that you can
check out after you've finished this
video
horizon forbidden west comes with a
great suite of options and accessibility
features to tweak and i really recommend
looking through the menus because some
of the options are incredibly useful
horizon is a beautiful game that
encourages exploration so i'd recommend
playing in explorer mode and changing
your hud to be dynamic that way there's
less on-screen hud clutter to improve
your immersion in a fight horizon can
throw a lot at you and different enemies
will have different weaknesses to give
yourself a little advantage change your
weapon wheel slowdown to slower that way
you can swap ammo types and weapons with
ease with less risk of getting run over
by a charging machine and i'm speaking
from experience because that happened to
me all the time if you find yourself in
the middle of the desert without an
overridden mount to ride to your next
location you might get a bit fed up with
needing to push in the thumb stick to
make aloy sprint you can set her to auto
sprint both on foot and when on a mount
which is very useful for traversing big
distances just don't forget to turn it
off if you're undertaking a platforming
section because otherwise you might miss
that pixel perfect jump
[Music]
horizon forbidden west has six huge
skill trees compared to zero dawn's four
allowing you to spec aloy in a way
that's more closely in line with how you
want to play the game the skill trees
can be overwhelming at first but because
upgrade points come in pretty thick and
fast it's in your best interest to
experiment leveling up and completing
missions including side content gives
you a couple of points per activity and
early skill tree abilities including
active skills and passive buffs are
relatively cheap a couple that i'd
recommend getting early on are silent
strike heel from the infiltrator tree to
gain back health when you use a silent
strike it's super useful if you're
taking out a fortress and you run out of
healing items in the survivor tree
invest in potent medicine to improve the
speed and amount of health you get from
medicinal berries and grab plant forager
as fast as you can aloy needs to do a
lot of ammo crafting so this comes in
clutch if you're big into laying traps
for your enemies definitely prioritize
that skill tree not only can you lay and
make traps quicker but you can take less
damage if you accidentally set off one
of your own
new to forbidden west are valor surges
powerful unlockable abilities that can
really give you the edge in a fight
think of them as aloy's ultimates you
can unlock a few and swap them on the
fly but as you can invest more points to
upgrade the abilities and make them
stronger here are some good ones to
prioritize in the infiltrator tree
stealth stalker allows you to
temporarily activate a cloaking device
in the middle of battle be aware that
you won't go completely invisible but
it's enough to help you lose some heat
at higher levels you get a damage boost
against unaware enemies and if you kill
them while cloaked you can prolong your
cloaking for longer also in the
infiltrator tree is radial blast which
acts as a knockback if you find yourself
completely surrounded by enemies firing
this off sends out a shock wave that
damages everyone around you and it's
extremely useful in a pinch
[Music]
if you take anything away from this
video i hope it's this the traps you lay
are op
when i played zero dawn i think i only
laid the ones in the tutorial and never
really bothered again in forbidden west
i was fully ready to commit to my bow
lifestyle again and look i fully admit
that when possible i am a stealth archer
but when i came up against a really
tough boss and was completely out of the
ammo type that carried its elemental
weakness i remembered that i had that
ammo in abundance in trap form those
traps decimated that boss's health bar
and fully built up the elemental bar too
meaning that it started to take extra
damage over time
now i stealth around battle arenas and
carefully lay traps everywhere there's
no greater joy than watching a machine
fall into your perfectly laid trap what
was that
aloy's focus is incredibly useful and
while you'll mostly use it to ping the
environment to find collectibles items
and handholds to climb you should be
using it at the start of every fight the
game tries to encourage you to do this
at the start but it's very easy to
forget but let me tell you the forbidden
west has a bunch of new machines to come
up against and it's in your best
interest to scan each and every one for
weaknesses when scanning with your focus
hit the touchpad to pause time
completely to read all the strengths and
weaknesses information way more easily
it tells you whether you're able to use
the machinist amount as well as giving
you a rundown of all the possible loot
you can get from it including valuable
information about how to get it off the
creature
this is definitely worth taking note of
as some resources get destroyed if you
don't detach them from the machine's
body before killing it plus some parts
drop weapons that you can use against
the machines you're fighting against so
make sure to hide in the bushes and scan
scan scan
don't get attached to one weapon
throughout the course of forbidden west
you'll find a truckload either through
the story or by buying them from the
many merchants you'll come across while
you can upgrade them at the workbench
honestly i would save those resources
and upgrade later in the game because at
the start you'll quickly get better
weapons anyway if you want to upgrade
anything at the start of the game you
should prioritize your pouches by
hunting organic animals that way you can
carry more weapons and ammo it's
important to make sure that every
elemental weakness is covered though so
you don't come up short against certain
machines and to help you out on the
battlefield make sure you have weapon
quick swap turned on in the menus
tapping l1 mid fight will swap to either
your last used weapon or a particular
one that you've predetermined in the
weapon wheel
across the course of the game aloy will
scavenge and pick up many many items and
while a lot can be used for crafting
some are just marked automatically as
valuables to sell instead of mass
selling those whenever you get to a
merchant make sure you're not actually
hanging on to something that could have
another use some machine hearts are used
for upgrades and other items can be used
to buy machine parts from salvage
contractor merchants
make sure it says that the item is only
used for selling for metal shards before
selling something you might regret
you might be tempted to mainline the
story but there's a lot of great side
content and character moments you'll
miss out on if you do the side quests
are really fun and well written and feel
fresher than the ones from zero dawn
there are also collectibles and relic
ruins which are climbing puzzles that
reminded me a lot of the ones from
assassin's creed ii
even unlocking the tall nexus one
requiring you to work a little harder to
reach the top of the giant creatures
when you get there though you get to
unlock the map and the shock wave it
emits kills all the surrounding machines
which gives you a little xp boost and
items to loot and you get to glide off
the top of it which i'd argue is the
biggest reward
so there's some starter tips for horizon
forbidden west but if you're looking for
help with combat our very own max
blumenthal is putting together his best
combat tips for you so make sure you
like this video and subscribe to
gamespot so you don't miss it i'm on
twitter at lucy james games thanks for
watching
[Music]
you